[applause]
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
some historians are met with scholarly
disagreement.
Others are met with something far more
telling.
A concerted wish
that they simply should not be heard.
Raymond Ibrahim belongs to the latter
category.
And that is why we are gathered here
today.
The Sappho Prize is not a popularity
award.
It is not an endorsement of consensus,
nor is it given to those who say what is
expected, what is comfortable, or what
is safe.
The Sappho Prize is an honor.
It recognizes courage,
and it serves as an encouragement to
stand firm.
Each year it is awarded to a person who
has shown fearlessness
and an uncompromising commitment in
defense of free expression.
Today we present the prize for the 20th
time.
Over the past two decades, the Free
Press Society has had the privilege of
honoring a remarkable line of thinkers
and defenders of free speech.
Individuals whose voices have shaped
public debate far beyond their own
countries.
Among them are Sir Roger Scruton,
Douglas Murray, Dennis Prager,
Daniel Pipes, and Tommy Robinson.
Voices who each in their own way have
demonstrated intellectual courage
and a refusal to bow to pressure.
Today Raymond Ibrahim takes his place in
that distinguished company.
For more than two decades, Raymond
Ibrahim has devoted his work to one of
the most sensitive
and systematically underreported issues
of our time.
The persecution of Christians in large
parts of the Muslim world
and the historical roots of conflicts
that in many that many in the West
prefer to explain away as social
tensions or the aftershocks of
colonialism.
His argument is simple
and for that very reason controversial.
Religion matters.
Texts matter.
History matters.
And violence does not become any less
real simply because it is inconvenient.
At a time when human rights otherwise
play a central role in the West's
understanding of itself,
it is striking how little attention is
given to the plight of Christians in
public debate.
Today Christians are the most persecuted
religious group in the world.
Yet their situation is often treated as
a marginal issue.
Something that may be politely
acknowledged, but rarely examined with
the seriousness and consistency it
demands.
Raymond Ibrahim has made it his task to
document this reality.
Through his monthly reports, he has
carefully gathered and presented
well-documented cases of violence,
discrimination,
forced conversion,
blasphemy prosecutions,
and the destruction of churches and
Christian property.
The picture that emerges is not one of
isolated incidents,
but of structural and persistent
persecution.
At the same time, another picture comes
into view.
A striking reluctance in parts of the
West to confront these facts openly.
Raymond Ibrahim has not limited himself
to describing the present.
In his historical works, he has sought
to place contemporary conflicts within a
broader and longer perspective.
Here he explains the historical and
theological background to both the
medieval and the present-day conflicts
between Islam and Christendom.
He brings into focus elements of that
background which are often overlooked or
consciously downplayed by many Western
academic historians.
For instance, through a reductionist
view of the medieval struggle between
Islam and Christendom,
a view that focuses narrowly on the
consequences of Pope Urban II's call for
the first crusade in 1095,
while overlooking the long history of
Islamic expansion and the persecution of
Eastern Christians that preceded it.
Ibrahim does not overlook this long
history.
He works with primary sources. He reads
classical Arabic texts. He analyzes the
ideological foundations of Jihadist
movements.
He insists that we cannot understand
reality if we decide in advance what may
and may not be investigated.
For precisely that reason, he has faced
attempts to silence him.
Lectures have been canceled. Accusations
have been deployed as weapons.
Institutions that ought to have defended
academic freedom have times failed to do
so.
Yet Raymond Ibrahim has stood firm.
And it is precisely this steadfastness
that the Sappho Prize seeks to honor.
The history of free speech is not a
history of comfort.
It is a history of resistance.
It is shaped by individuals who refuse
to be told what they may think,
what they may examine, and what they may
say.
It is also shaped by truths that at
first seem too difficult to voice,
but later prove to be indispensable.
When millions of people living under
theocratic regimes today call out for
freedom and rise up against religious
oppression, we are reminded that
religion is not only a matter of
identity.
It can also be a matter of power.
It can involve coercion.
And it can used to be used to justify
violent repression.
Raymond Ibrahim has devoted his life to
breaking the silence surrounding these
realities.
He has done so as a historian, as a
writer, and as a public intellectual.
He has done so with a perseverance that
commands respect, even from those who
may disagree with his conclusions.
The Sappho Prize is not awarded to those
who are necessarily really right about
everything.
It is awarded to those who are willing
to take the risk of speaking what they
believe to be true.
It is awarded to those who understand
that free expression does not endure by
itself,
that it depends on voices that refuse to
fall silent, and under and under courage
not to be intimidated.
Therefore,
it is with both pride and gratitude
that the Free Press Society today awards
the Sappho Prize 2026 to Raymond
Ibrahim.
Thank you for your resolve.
Thank you for your endurance.
And thank you for reminding us that the
struggle for free speech always begins
with the willingness to say what others
would rather not hear.
Congratulations.
>> [applause]
[applause]
>> Okay.
Well, thank you very much, Aya, and
thank you all for coming. And uh you
very much for bestowing such a wonderful
award on me. I really appreciate it. It
means a lot. I'm happy to hear that my
efforts over these more than two decades
have
uh culminated this way. This is a good
good thing that I never really expected,
actually. And um so to see it happen is
definitely a sort of validation for what
one's been doing. Cuz as you can
imagine, in the theme that we're
discussing, when someone goes against
the grain so much,
he might at one point think he's wrong
and, you know, start to succumb. But not
me. I continued nonetheless because um
it just and I think this will be part of
what we'll discuss is the importance of
the truth.
Not necessarily what people want to hear
or don't want to hear, but what the
truth is, because the truth is very
important. If you can't if a society if
the first premise,
you know, how logic and philosophy is,
you have a first premise and then
something has to fit on top of it. If
the first premise is inherently false,
everything you build on it is going to
be ultimately also false and the whole
thing will crumble at one point or
other. That's why you need a strong
foundation built on truth.
Now,
for this talk I'd like to um
discuss before you we can talk about how
we got here, we have to know where we
came from. So obviously, that's why I've
always been very interested in history.
And um
I find it intrinsically interesting, but
I also find it very uh
enlightening in so far as trying to
understand what's happening in the now,
in the today. So that's one of the main
reasons I've always gravitated towards
and found my answers in history.
And in the context of what we're
discussing uh basically the West in
general, Denmark of course in
particular,
and the question of Islam in general,
which is of course my field. My field as
I have pointed out has always been the
nexus of Islam and Christendom
historically past and present from a
doctrinal view, historical um
developments and so forth. So what I'd
like to do is give you a brief recap of
the of the true history, which you may
not be acquainted with, especially if
you went to all the good public schools.
Um
And uh you know, from there we'll reach
to uh the modern era and various
conclusions.
And as I do this, one of the things that
I've always liked and one of the things
that I've always um inspired me in my
studies going way back is whenever I
find continuity. Okay? By continuity I
mean or patterns. So when I see certain
things that have happened in the past
and I see they're happening in the same
way, maybe in a different guise,
different superficial veneer, but it's
the same essence, I always take note of
that and find it fascinating because uh
it it really tells you that what we're
talking about, whatever the topic may
be, is not some aberration because if
it's been around for millennia, then
it's something we should take seriously.
So briefly, the the Islam when we talk
about Islam
a lot of people like to talk too much
about the actual religion itself and all
the problems it has and you know, how
horrific it is and I actually don't do
that. My concern is what does Islam have
to say towards me, the infidel. Okay?
Because as a non-Muslim, a lot of people
will attack Islam say it's draconian and
you know, the way they treat and they do
this and it's barbaric and polygamy and
all that. As far as I'm concerned,
that's inter-civilizational, which means
as long as it affects them, that's their
own group, they want to live that way,
that's one thing. So for me, I've always
been interested in ascertaining
precisely what it is that actually
impacts us, the non-Muslims.
And if you look at it, it's really uh
three intertwined doctrines out of all
the many doctrines and and I'm not
saying the other ones are not bad or
problematic. I'm just saying they don't
really concern us.
The ones the the inherent one that you
would that you that very few people are
aware of
um is in in Arabic it's called al-wala'
wal-bara'.
And this can be translated as loyalty
and enmity or love and hate. Wala' means
basically loyalty, um
allegiance, befriending someone, love.
And bara' means disavowal, renunciation,
up to hatred. Okay?
And that is an ironclad doctrine in the
Quran. Okay? So Muslims are called to
have wala', love, loyalty, etc. towards
fellow Muslims.
And they're called by Allah to have
hate, enmity, disavowal of all
non-Muslims. This is an ironclad uh um
uh doctrine.
And one of the key verses
is Quran 60 verse 4 or sura 60 A of 4,
where it talks about
you it says you have an excellent
example in Ibrahim, not me, the prophet
Abraham, who they call Ibrahim
uh because as you know, Islam
appropriates biblical characters and
gives them different roles. So Ibrahim
in the Quran is the biblical Genesis
Abraham.
And as we know in that story, Abraham
basically leaves the land that God calls
him out of and calls him to another land
and that's all we know about it. But in
the Islamic Quranic rendering, before he
leaves, he tells his former kinsmen
hatred and enmity will forever reign
between us until you believe in Allah
alone. Okay? And that is the cornerstone
of this particular doctrine that the
non-Muslim must have hatred for the non-
the I'm sorry, the Muslim must have
hatred for the non-Muslim. Okay? And as
I said, the the corollary or the other
aspect is he must be loyal and help the
um the Muslim.
And this is so ironclad, I've seen so
many modern-day clerics talking about
it, of course in Arabic. I've translated
them. I have a video of one man, an
Egyptian cleric, where he sits there and
he's teaching. He's he's well-known uh
sheikh and he tells
uh all his pupils that Islam Islam
allows Muslim men to marry women from
the people of the book, which means Jews
and Christian Jewish and Christian
women.
So it allows that.
Speaking of
Sounds rather tribal, but okay, so
um
so it allows that, but he was telling
them, yes, you can marry them and you
can enjoy them
carnally and do whatever, but you have
to hate them.
Because you you can't let the hate get
extinguished and and he gets into the
details and he says for example,
uh and these are all these Islamic weird
doctrines, but he says one one asks,
well, so if I come in the house and
she's there, I can't say hi to her.
He says you can say hi if your kids are
there and but you mean you mean the hi
to them. But it's kind of generic so she
can feel like it's a hi, you know, but
but you have to have the hatred for
them. So this is a real thing. This is
in their doctrines. This is not made up.
Now,
in and of itself, I call that the
metaphysical sort of um underpinning of
all the problems that we have. Now, how
does this doctrine manifest itself? If
you're taught to hate someone
and you come from a 7th century tribal
um
uh um environment like Muhammad,
uh what how does that manifest itself?
Well, it manifests in what he called
jihad. Okay? So now you go and you
attack the people that you hate,
the infidels, and you do whatever needs
done be not needs done to them.
And so
why I think this is important is because
some people people are aware of jihad,
but they think it's just, you know,
warfare and it's but there's actually
it's guided by hatred. And that you can
see this in the text when you see what
happens to the conquered infidel. It's
not just we conquered you or we killed
you or we enslaved you. There's a whole
ritual of sort of a degrading measures
that are meted out to the infidel. And
this is especially the case with those
who are enslaved, which at some point I
may talk about.
But so that's the doctrine
uh that creates the animus. The animus
manifests itself into jihad. And then
when the jihad is complete and
successful, wherever it is, it conquers
a non-Muslim region, then the people who
are subjugated are either you either
become one of us and you get equal
rights.
If you're if you're a people of the
book, we give you the option where you
uh you can maintain your religion, but
you have to pay extra tribute. It's
called jizya.
And you have to know your place and you
have to feel sub humbled and subdued.
That's actually in the Quran. Quran 9:29
says fight the people of the book until
they pay jizya with willingness and feel
themselves utterly subdued.
And then the Islamic jurists, of course,
they take a verse like that and then
they build an entire um a
a a doctrine around it.
And and they find also things from the
Hadith, which is the sayings and deeds
of Muhammad. And then his sayings and
deeds are such, of course, that it
enforces the um the sort of subjugation
thing. For example, Muhammad said if you
come across
uh a Christian or a Jew, make the way
it's written in Arabic, push them to the
side, make them feel uncomfortable, kind
of ostracize them. Okay? Don't you're
not you're never supposed to say salaam.
If you're familiar, Muslims will always
say salaam alaikum and the response is
alaikum salaam. You're never supposed to
say that to a non-Muslim. Okay? So
again, you can see it's not just that
there's warfare, it's that hatred is
there and it culminates once that person
has been subjugated. And that of course
is the history of what has happened to
uh
much of the of the non-Muslim world,
especially the Christian world. So that
basically those are the I just those are
only the three topics doctrinally that I
really think you need to know about. And
what really made them powerful, if you
think about it, is Muhammad his genius,
as I call it, is he took his the tribal
mores of his 7th century essentially
Bedouin style, which was immensely
tribalistic. And as you know, tribalism
is basically us versus them. Us being
the blood blood kin. Everyone outside
the the tribe is enemy. We kill them,
plunder them, enslave them, whatever.
He took that
and he now deified it. He rearticulated
it through a theological paradigm. So
now it's no longer us, our blood,
against the others. It's us, the ummah,
which means the Muslims collectively,
against everyone else. So it was the
same logic, but just a slight paradigm
shift. And so it wasn't This is why it's
it's really interesting historically,
all the people who converted to Islam
were in were originally tribal peoples,
not sedentary people. So you had the
Arabs were the first, then the Berbers
later on, and then you had the um who
who became the Moors in Spain. Then you
had the Turks, you had the Tatars or the
Mongols who did become Islamic. And I
believe that's because the the message
of Islam, as I'm explaining it to you,
just completely comported with their
pre-existing way of life, which is we
raid on the other and we take their
stuff and we enslave them and we kill
them. But now
we do that and the more we killed and
possibly if we are killed, then we even
get rewarded in heaven. So, it's even
better than secular tribalism. Now, this
is deified tribalism, which means now
the more you do this and the more you
hate on these people and you and you
plunder them and kill them and destroy
them, that's a sign of piety. And
Muhammad tells his followers that, you
know, that he there's in the Quran
there's one verse, I believe 9:111,
it says, "He who fights and kills and is
killed is gets the highest level of
martyrdom uh in paradise." Which
includes uh supernatural
um bosomed uh very uh supernatural women
who are kind of almost pornographically
described in the Quran as um
pleasuring his favorites in perpetuity.
Um and there's all sorts of weird things
like uh you know, their hymen comes back
and you can continue doing it forever
and the erection never softens and
that's actually in the Islamic texts,
believe it or not. Um
so, that's uh
so so there it is, okay? You have you
you now understand that the doctrine
itself is not so strange. It's really
tribal worldview, but it's just been
given a a theological veneer. And now
which made it more potent, okay?
That's all I want to say about the
doctrine. We can talk some more at
another point, but now I'd like to get
into a quick recap of the history.
I often think the history is much more
important because if you talk about
doctrine, as you know, a lot of people
complain and say, "Well, so what? Well,
the Bible has verses that are violent or
you know, you get that." So, I always
say, "Fine, let's put the books away now
and let's see what happened really in
history." Did the Muslims do this? Did
they actually uphold what we're talking
about as far as what's written in the
Quran and codified in what's called
Sharia law? Or is this just uh
Islamophobia on our part?
So, a quick recap of the history is in
order and basically it long story short,
Muhammad dies in 632
AD and from and that's when the Jihad
blows up out of Arabia and quickly the
two superpowers of the time, which was
uh the Eastern Roman Empire, which we
call the Byzantine Empire, and the
Persian Empire, the Sasanian Empire, who
were they were the two superpowers,
Islam overran and essentially conquered
both of them. They didn't conquer the
capital of the Roman Empire, but they
conquered its many lands in the Middle
East. So, it conquered greater Syria,
which actually encompassed the entire
Middle East, so all the modern-day
states you can think of, Jordan,
Lebanon, Israel, Palestinian
territories, even portions of Iraq, all
of that was primarily Christian.
All that was conquered, Syria, of
course, and then Egypt, again, one of
the oldest Christian nations, all the
way westward, um you know, Algeria,
Tunisia, Libya, Morocco, and then into
Spain, okay? And then Spain got
conquered. And I give you the date 632
cuz it's very easy to remember, that's
the day Muhammad year he died. One
century after his death is 732 and
that's the famous Battle of Tours,
right in the middle of France. So, in
one century, Muslims
live living up to what I described to
you, the concept of Jihad, went and
conquered all that vast territory.
And most people don't realize all that
territory when you went back that time
in the 7th century,
and if you looked at uh the
you know, the the old world, Europe and
the North in the Middle East and so
forth,
the Christian world, most of it was in
those territories. So, the older
Christian territories, the where you had
the more learned uh fathers and church
fathers,
uh where all the councils were being
held, it was all in that area. Only
there were five major sees historically.
One was Rome and the other four were in
the East, Constantinople, Alexandria,
Antioch, Jerusalem. All four of those
were swallowed up. So, in a way, that's
if we say there's five and four got
swallowed up, that's almost saying like
80% of the Christian world was conquered
through violent force from Jihad.
But, they never taught you that in your
schools.
Um
so,
that's uh that's something to keep in
mind. And then the Mediterranean, of
course, people forget this part, but the
Mediterranean was completely devastated.
Every single island was conquered,
occupied, enslaved. There's very
horrific things um that I recall reading
about what happened to the islands
during these early times.
To the point that Ibn Khaldun, uh
well-known Muslim philosopher, he he
characterized the Mediterranean as it
became a Muslim lake. Well, it wasn't a
Muslim lake historically. Actually, it
was the um it was where the North Europe
and North Africa and the Middle East
were actually all part of Christendom,
one world. And that's why Rome had
commerce with Egypt and with Syria and
vice versa because they were all
Christian at this point in the 7th
century. But, once that happened,
basically Europe uh not even all of it
because as we saw, Spain was conquered,
but the rest of Europe was basically cut
off and this is when historians used to
call the Dark Ages, okay? So,
they tell you
they try to pin the Dark Ages on you.
They say the Vikings came and ruined
everything around 800.
But, actually, it was more the Muslims
what they did.
And uh and there's an entire uh thesis
by a his another historian who, of
course, got shut up, but this is an
early 19th century historian,
Henri Pirenne, um I believe he was
French, but he wrote a whole book called
um Charlemagne and Muhammad and he
basically said, "Without Muhammad, the
rise of Charlemagne and the feudal
system and all that would have been
inconceivable because it was Muhammad
and his followers who completely remade
the old world and and split off Europe
from what it was once connected to,
which is to say, the East,
Constantinople as well." Um so, that was
a very traumatic event that occurred in
the Christian world and like I said, led
to the beginning of of the Dark Ages,
which um
and then
you know, you can look wherever you
look, Spain, for example, that was
that's to me a microcosm of Jihad versus
Crusade for centuries. Okay? They they
try to tell you Spain is some was some
sort of multicultural heaven.
Um yeah, we'll get it to that. But,
actually, it was if you look at it, uh
so when the Muslims conquered it, right
before they got to Tours, there was in
the in the if you envision the Iberian
Peninsula, in the northwest quadrant,
this is uh this is the area where it's
just rough mountains, kind of
wilderness, nobody really wants to live
there supposedly back then. And
something like a handful of Christians
were holed up there that did not submit
to Islam as in it at the way the others
had had. And the Muslims in their text
say, "Ah, who cares? They're just a
bunch of, you know,
>> [snorts]
>> yokels living in the woods, what are
they going to do?"
And then anyway, century after century,
they started to get stronger and come
down and down further south, further
south and this is, of course, called the
Reconquista. Now, to their mind, they
were essentially this was a
proto-crusade. They were reclaiming
Christian lands that had been conquered
by Islam very violently. And that went
on and it's I just find and here's the
amazing thing, this goes on for
literally like seven centuries until
it's finally around 1492, 1500, the the
war with Islam is is is finally at an
end. And it's all out of vicissitudes
and a lot of atrocities, a lot of
Jihadist organizations would come from
North Africa. One battle is the Battle
of Sagrajas in the 12th century, they
built a mountain of Christian heads and
climbed the top it singing praises to
Allah and that sort of thing was not not
as aberrant as you would think. So, that
was that's Spain for you.
But, they'll tell you it was but what
about the Golden Age? What about, you
know, everyone lived in peace.
So, let me explain to you real quick, I
think this is important, what the Golden
Age was and I'll give you an analogy.
And the Golden Age for Spain and also
the Abbasid Caliphate because um
in in centered around Baghdad cuz that
also is called the Golden Age. But, the
best way to understand it is like this.
The reason historians will tell you it
was a Golden Age because they look at
Spain and they see it had a lot of
material wealth and it was prosperous
and it was culturally refined possibly
and they had um you know, better science
obviously than Dark Age Europe because
they're the ones who cut off the access
to science, obviously. Um but but the
Islamic everything that I just told you,
the atrocities, that was still there,
100%. So, the best way to to understand
this is
imagine, you know, these what is it? UAE
or Dubai that they have those beautiful
skyscrapers, right? Those countries.
Imagine um you know, it's 100 200 years
from now, the whole world's changed, we
don't know anything about what really
happened. And you look at those
countries and you say, "But, look, that
we know one thing about that that
country, UAE or or those areas, we they
had a lot of great architecture, okay?
And they were Muslim. Therefore,
based on that simple logic, Mus Islam
leads to wonderful progress."
But, we know, we can look at it. Yeah,
they do have that progress or that's
they have those things, the buildings
and the technology, but one, it wasn't
made by them at all
and two, they still are following a 7th
century Bedouin mentality within amongst
each other. So, I submit to you that's
how you should understand of the
so-called Golden Age in Spain. It was
the same thing. They had wealth, al-
almost all of it plundered by from
Europeans. They had slaves, almost all
of whom were plundered from Europe. And
they were powerful and opulent, okay?
But, beneath that, it wasn't because
they created anything, it was because
they were taking it, but beneath that it
was the same usual Islamic stuff. So, as
as one example,
and historians don't like it when I
bring this up, but apparently at the
golden at the height of the golden age
that they reference cuz it was very very
short-lived. It's something around in
the mid-7th century, maybe.
Like through two three decades.
Um well, during that same time, there's
what's called the Martyrs of Córdoba.
And who these are, they were about 50
Christians cuz Christians were
subjugated by the Muslims at the time.
These aren't the ones who rebelled.
These are the ones who were living under
Islam.
And because the way Muslims were
treating them, you remember what I told
you about subjugating, making them feel
humiliated, etc. etc. These Christians
just kind of couldn't take anymore,
became so frustrated, and just started
speaking up very vocally. They deserve
the Saffle prize, actually. They started
saying, "Your prophet is is a demon.
There's only one Lord, Jesus Christ.
This and that." And all 50 of them were
tortured,
skinned alive. One woman was boiled
alive, beheaded, and crucified. Okay?
This is during the golden age.
So, the golden age is much more about
material opulence, which yeah, Muslims
would like to acquire and they can, and
much less about a somehow progressive
civilization. Okay? It never changed,
and that's why I think that analogy with
these rich Gulf states make sense. Okay?
Yeah, they have good stuff, but it's not
because of their civilization, and their
own culture is still like what it always
is. Okay.
Now, moving along,
um then you we're talking about this
vast conquest. So, basically 2/3 of
Christendom was conquered in 1 century,
right? The Mediterranean was destroyed.
It was a It was a traumatic experience
for Europe. Spain, I told you, was
engulfed in a war. And then later on,
you get the Turks. Now, the Turks rise
up, they become Muslims, and they
essentially became the standard-bearers
of jihad, better than the Arabs,
actually.
Um a lot of historians will tell you
that, that they took to jihad even more
fanatically.
And um I'm I'm thinking now of the
Seljuk Turks, especially. These are the
ones who are come right before the First
Crusade. They're running amok. They're,
you know, they're attacking. You may
have heard the of the Armenian genocide
at the hand of Turks. It actually goes
back a a thousand years before the one
you know. The one you know is in what,
for World War I and late 1800s.
It actually starts in the around 1050.
And that's when the Turks start entering
in what, greater Armenia. And according
to contemporary sources, they burned
thousands of churches, slaughtered
countless people, enslaved even more.
And again, all throughout this, keep in
mind,
if you dig in the sources, you will see
that the the religious hostility that I
tried to um
express to you was always there. It
wasn't just one group conquer another.
There So, for example, out of nowhere,
after they conquer something, then they
go and break the cross and drag it in
the dirt. So, obviously, there's an
ideological element to it, just like
when ISIS does that today.
And um
So,
uh and so, this is also why the the
Ottomans, they overrun basically um
Asia Minor, which become Now, it's
called Turkey. Of course, it was one of
the oldest Christian regions in the
world. It figures prominently in the
Book of Revelation. Paul wrote letters
to it. Um and now, of course, it's a
bastion of Islam. It's It's Turkey. And
then from there, of course, it gets
worse, and they come finally into
Europe. Constantinople sacked in 1453.
Very horrific stuff what happens at that
point, and a lot of symbolic imagery
again degrading the Christian faith and
upholding Islam
uh very much. And uh you know, all the
Balkans. You know the wars, of course.
Um
what happens to these various nations.
Hungary stood, you know, fought back for
a while, but it too was under the
Ottoman yoke for 150 years, and all the
other nations south of it in the
Balkans. And of course,
I believe that's one of the reasons that
the Eastern and Central um European
nations
are less fuzzy towards Muslims than you
are.
They have that sort of
recent memory uh history. In fact,
that's what they say. People like Victor
Orbán literally say, "We don't want
Muslims among us. We know what it's
like. We've lived with them for 150
years."
So, I think that um I really believe
because
what I'm talking about now is much
closer to our times. These attacks from
the Ottomans were happening in 15th,
16th, 17th century, right? Up until
1683. Now, you have a massive Ottoman
army surrounding Vienna.
Okay? And it could have It could have
gone And it was It was always piecemeal.
I mean, it was to get one, consolidate
it, and then get another. And the goal
was always to get Rome, of course, being
the the central symbolic Christian head
of Western Europe. Um so, that goes on,
but you know, it's even funny that
and and few Americans understand this,
even America's very first war as a
nation is with Muslims. And not just any
Muslims, Muslims who are talking exactly
like ISIS would talk. So,
um and I'm talking about the First
Barbary War, which um America was
America's first war after gained
independence from Britain.
So, basically, all these Muslims who
were uh living in North Africa,
Europeans called North Africa Barbary
because that's where the barbarians live
because all they did is come and raid
and kill and destroy. It's It's hard to
really express to you these things
unless you really read the sources. I
mean, the people were terrified. It's It
This is the problem with history when
someone talks about it, and I just give
you numbers, you know, X amount died, X
amount. It doesn't really capture the
sort of visceral experience that people
had when you see people descending on
you and, you know, tying you up, taking
your wife, your daughter, raping them,
enslaving. Um So, that's uh that's why
that was known as Barbary. That's the
land of the barbarians where we want
nothing to do with.
So, those guys started attacking, and
this is funny, goes back to the jizya.
Okay?
So, Britain was actually paying tribute
to these Barbary pirates as a way for
them to not attack British vessels. They
said, "Instead of fighting them, we're
just giving them the their money." Okay?
So, it was considered jizya. They took
it, and they let them go.
Now, when the Barbary pirates got wind
that America and Britain had fought, and
now America was no longer covered by
Britain's jizya,
America became free game. And so, it
started attacking American vessels,
enslaving its its sailors, doing all
sorts of horrific things to them.
And then finally, and it just shows you
kind of the disconnect that we're going
to deal with here, that we're talking
about the modern-day disconnect. It goes
all the way back to the enlightened
thinker, Thomas Jefferson.
Because he went and he met with the
ambassador, one of the ambassadors from
Barbary, to try to to get get to release
the enslaved Americans.
And then look what he wrote. Then after
his meeting, he sent a letter to
Congress
dated March 28, 1786. We still have this
letter. And here's what Jefferson wrote.
Quote, "We took the liberty to make some
inquiries concerning the grounds of
their Barbary's pretensions to make war
upon nations who had done them no
injury.
And observed that we considered all my
all mankind as our friends who had done
us no wrong nor had given us any
provocation." So, Jefferson started off
by saying, "Look, uh
you know, we we've done you no wrong. We
like all mankind. Let's Can't we just
work together?" And then he continues,
"The ambassador answered us that it was
founded on the laws of their prophet,
that it was written in their Quran, that
all nations who should not have
acknowledged their authority were
sinners or infidels, that it was their
right and duty to make war upon them
wherever they could be found, and to
make slaves of all they could take as
prisoners. And that every Musliman,
meaning Muslim, who should be slain in
battle was sure to go to paradise."
Okay?
Doesn't that sound exactly like
something ISIS would say?
And And here we are, you know. So, we
started And And by the way, this I This
is the only quote I'm giving you, but in
all the battles and in all the the
confrontations that I spoke about
earlier, that was the logic. Whenever
the Muslim met with the Christian or
whatever to parley, this is how the
Muslim would say it was. He would say,
"It's our religion. You're the infidel,
and it's our right to attack and kill
you." That's just the way it is.
Um now,
that long history, we now need to talk
about what happened to Christians during
this time. Okay?
Uh they were vastly persecuted. It's not
the story that you hear. I mean, the the
apologetics that I hear nowadays, they
say, for example, "Oh, the only reason
that they took jizya from Christians was
so that because the Christians didn't
want to serve in the military." So, that
was their way of contributing to the war
effort. There's nothing whatsoever in
any Islamic source that says that. Not
to mention, a Christian could not join a
Muslim army because he's an infidel, and
he's seen as a fifth column. That So,
I'm just showing you the kind of lies
that they'll try to do instead of saying
the truth, which is, yeah, the jizya was
a humiliating tax. They try to worm it
and make it sound like, "No, no, it was
just uh it was trying to be a military
exemption for the guy. He didn't want to
fight." Okay? Not true.
Now, the three choices that you may be
familiar with, which I alluded to in
Quran 9:29, which says basically fight
the infidel until he converts or he dies
or he pays tribute and he lives as a
second-class citizen. That was the
constant. That was the norm all
throughout the Islamic world. Okay? And
we know that because we have texts and
charters and um you know, tax tax
documents still left, and it shows that.
It There's some that talk about how when
the Christian or the Jew would come and
pay tribute, the jizya, he had to come
on all fours like an animal as part of
the humiliation ritual or or the tax
collect collector would pull his beard
and slap him on the head, okay? So that
that's Imagine that's the sort of thing
and
of course in that climate churches
there's extreme
there's extreme restrictions on them
even though in theory there shouldn't be
but and they get attacked and they get
burned. Long story short it like now it
all comes down to the whim of the people
and up until now you look at these
countries it's funny I tell you about
continuity I'll read something about in
800 about how one Christian in Egypt did
something that upset a Muslim man then
the Muslim man accused all the
Christians of something like blasphemy
then all the Muslims rise up and attack
and burn and kill and this goes on for 2
weeks and the authorities look the other
way.
That happens like here now almost every
other week all the time I come across
these stories, okay? So that's what I
mean by the continuity not much has
really changed, okay? But and guess now
it
guess where guess when the jizya was
finally abolished and by who?
The big bad evil white man.
During the colonial era you know that
evil time
when they went there the European powers
they actually made sure that that was
abolished and they tried to bring in a
sort of equal type citizen irrespective
of religion, all right?
But as far as how Christians during the
era during the times the historic times
I was talking about just to give you
again just one simple anecdote
that I've never I know
I'll tell you what people say of this
guy. So there was a Fatimid caliph in
Egypt
and his name is Hakim bi-Amr Allah.
A Fatimid caliph would be a Shia caliph
actually most people don't know Egypt
was run by Shias for almost 2 3
centuries
and that Al-Azhar in Cairo which is a
bastion of Sunni learning was actually
created as a Shia madrasah.
But anyway this caliph because he was a
Shia and the population of Egypt was
still primarily Sunni in order to show
his bonafides and make them trust him he
went and destroyed 30,000 churches and
including some synagogues in Egypt. This
is at a time of course this is
we're talking about the 11th century.
So this is at a time when that region is
still heavily Christian it's still not
Muslim which majority but the sources
that say this are
Muslim sources. Now you know what so you
know how Western historians treat this
guy? He's known as the mad caliph
because what he did had no rhyme or
reason no sense he was just a crazy guy
and please don't think he was
representative of your typical caliph
and it yet to be sure he did a lot more
but actually the typical the typical
caliph also engaged in that sort of
thing maybe not at that mass scale of
30,000 obviously there probably weren't
many churches left after him but I'm
just showing you the sorts of things
that would happen and the point is you
know people say well okay Christians and
Jews they had their they had their pact
with the Muslims they're paying tribute
they're feeling subdued etc. But that's
only as good as Muslims want it to be.
So anytime like I said a Muslim or a
group of Muslims just rise up for
whatever reason and attack the
Christians that's it you don't have any
rights you can't go to the authority the
authority either turns a blind eye or
maybe even aids and that happens till
this very day. In Egypt for example
there's this an entire
criminal network of Islamists who target
young girls
for abduction for rape and they and they
and they shame them and you know and
they take videos and they do all sorts
of things so they all so they can design
so they can convert to Islam.
And it's well known that the authorities
don't do anything and some of them are
working with them. And it makes sense
why not because they think what they're
doing is right they're Muslims these are
infidels we're helping them out. What's
what's what's so bad about making them
come to see the light of Islam, okay?
So and then the worst of all and that's
what I mean when we talk about the
historical thing but we're also seeing
it in the modern is the slave raids.
So
you know there was the jihad and there
was all that but it always culminated
with massive slave raids. So the
Ottomans
I would be reading a a primary chronicle
and it would just write it would note a
date and say the Ottomans came and
attacked this or that city usually in
the Balkans and they left with 60,000
slaves
or they came here they left with 20,000
slaves or they came here and they just
left with 120,000 slaves and like really
big numbers and it describes and women
and children naked shackled being
whipped and if they can't run far enough
they get killed. So pretty brutal stuff.
The Barbary pirates that I was telling
you about in North Africa we we know for
a fact cuz one historian has actually
taken the time to collate all the
information and he says there was at
least 1.25 million European slaves
within just one century between like
1560 and 1660 all Europeans that were
brought there and again very very
horrifically treated.
But like I said the Ottomans and even
more so the Tatars
the Mongols who became
Muslim primarily those associated with
the Golden Horde and the Crimea Khanate
those
unfortunately it's very hard to get the
numbers but when you really you get the
sense that we're talking about many many
millions okay of peoples of the Slavic
peoples
they're called that for a reason okay?
were being enslaved and taken away and
just going through essentially hell,
okay? And these pirates just to give you
an idea I mean if you look at the map of
Europe as you know it so I've already
show if you looked again 7th century map
of Christian world before Islam first
thing you see is 3/4 taken away and then
you know Spain taken away half of France
for a long time you had even after the
Battle of Tours you had Muslims in
sconced in France. They had a base in
Switzerland I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it right Valais small area
where they actually had a
a base a raiding base. They attacked and
almost sacked Rome in around 854 or 850s
roughly around that time. So this was a
constant thing they went as far as
Iceland and the Faroe Islands to collect
slaves. They had an island named Lundy
it still exists off the side of Britain
which they used as a base and they
raided Baltimore and Ireland
and all these northern they may have
come to Denmark at that point who knows.
There there is in fact some writings
about that which I haven't pursued yet.
So that was the story of what of Islam
and the the West and the Christian West.
Now let's fast forward to today.
What I when when the great age of deceit
fell upon us and when truth gave way to
relativism and when good became bad and
bad became good.
That's where we are, okay? Well this is
obviously its own topic and there's no
time for that but I think we all
intuitively sense what I'm talking about
and you know just to keep it on the
current topic history now is taught in a
way in the West that exists to demonize
the Christian West any which way it can
and to exonerate and make Muslims look
like the victims.
And there's a reason for that. You know
history's not just some dry useless
thing
history is more is a very powerful
weapon the way you use it or misuse it
in this case and I often I've coined
this
fake history.
You we've all heard of fake news of
course and fake news
does its damage but it's ephemeral it
comes and it goes. Fake history is a lot
more subtle and a lot more dangerous
because what fake history is
is you create a false narrative so let's
say I say actually Christians have been
attacking Muslims for centuries and
Muslims are innocent. Let's say that's
the fake history I say that. Well guess
what you're going to see everything
today in current events through that
lens and it's going to confirm what
you're being told. You're going to be
when they tell you well whites are
racist that's or whites are Islamophobic
or whites are xenophobic
it's going to make sense if you believe
the fake history. And the history that
is coming out of the academic
departments is really fake, okay? It's
not grounded in the sources that I've
looked at a lot of these sources I
actually collated with my work at the
Library of Congress so I was really
lucky to access a lot of primary
materials that completely give the lie
to what's being taught today mainstream
academic discourse.
And I'll give you just one perfect
example and I used to go to Georgetown
University in Washington D.C. and there
was a very famous professor his name was
John Esposito and very famous he was he
was the go-to guy you know intelligence
agencies cuz this was around 911 2011
2001 sorry
and yeah he was everywhere he's he's
written multiple books all of them
praise and he was the editor of the
Oxford History of Islam that's very
prestigious.
He has in one of his books this line
which I've said so many times cuz it's
so ludicrous I've essentially memorized
it.
But he says five centuries of peaceful
coexistence between Christians and
Muslims elapsed before an imperial papal
power play led to a series of so-called
holy wars that have left an enduring
legacy of mistrust and resentment. So
what he's saying is what he's saying is
from the dawn of Islam until the first
crusade it was all peaceful coexistence
until those evil papal power play the
Crusaders decided to just for the heck
of it let's go and ruin everything let's
ruin all this peace.
Nothing about how 3/4 of the Christian
world was violently conquered nothing
about in one year 30,000 churches being
destroyed nothing about the millions of
Christians being enslaved before the
first crusade. So that's what I mean by
very dangerous fake history. But, like I
said, there's a reason it's being said.
If you believe this fake history, that
will be the paradigm where which with
you will always see current events in
and it will inform it will help support
the idea that yeah, the Muslims are
victims. It's the Christians, it's the
Europeans, it's the white people who are
evil, okay?
And um
So, now we come to the real final point,
which is the big the big the the
elephant in the room known as hate
speech. Um This is essentially, if you
don't know what's going on, it's um this
truth has been labeled hate speech and
banned. But, that word hate speech is
just a euphemized weapon to make you
shut up and get along with what we're
trying to do and stop inconveniencing us
with your truths, okay? So, now truth
has become hate speech. Now, we're
supposed to be a society that instead of
just saying here's the truth, let's
build on the truth because if you can't
build on the truth, then you're not
you're not building anything. It's going
to sink. It's going to break, okay?
Instead of and and the truth can be
ugly. I get that. The truth can be
uncomfortable. But, hiding the truth and
and and rearranging it and whitewashing
it and putting a falsehood in its place
and then trying to build something atop
that, like I said, it's destined to um
failure.
And we've reached the point and even
think of the logic, hate speech. So, now
truth must take a second seat rather
than someone getting offended. You know,
what kind of society runs on principle
that making sure nobody gets offended is
all we're we're about. I mean, that's
that's a soon-to-die kind of society if
that's your ultimate criterion. If it's
more important that some individual
doesn't get offended, that's more
important than getting the truth out.
Something's really wrong. And um
in the context of this wonderful prize
I've received, I'll tell you a little
bit of my experiences that I alluded to
to show you the sorts of things that I
had to go through.
My you know, my so-called experience
with cancel culture.
And these terms, you know, it's funny
because I was I was suffering these
terms before they had a name.
I didn't know what they were called,
being canceled and all that. But, this
actually starts in college. Um in
college, I was lucky I had um many of
you may know, Victor Davis Hanson was my
professor in the early years. We're
talking about 28, 29 years ago. Great
guy and um that that's probably why I
liked history and wanted to continue
with history.
And um I got my master's degree with
him. He was on my
the chair of my committee and so forth.
And then right after it, 2001 9/11
happens and he actually was encouraging
me say you should get your PhD. Long
story short, I applied and I got
accepted by one of the best schools,
which was Georgetown in Washington, D.C.
They had a very strong um
Middle East Islamic studies program. And
I went there and um I got good grades,
but I can tell my professors did not
like me.
And they would even tell me and they
would argue with me about what I wrote.
And in one of one of them actually like
flipped out, you know, it's what's
called triggering as I've learned since,
okay? Uh but he did this in like, I
don't know, 2004 maybe. Um and I you
know, it left a bad taste in my mouth.
And at the then at that time, I got a
job at the Library of Congress as I
mentioned and I became a full-time job
and eventually got a book deal and I
started gravitating away from happily
school. But, I also remember going to
also in D.C., Catholic University of
America, which is a big Catholic school.
I went there just to study Semitic
languages as part of my work at the
Library of Congress cuz I dealt with a
lot of Semitic languages.
And I remember taking a course with a
priest. And when he saw what I wanted
you know, what I wanted to write about,
which was conflict between Muslims and
Christians, he just got so like, "No,
no, why don't we talk about dialogue?
And why don't you how about we do a
dialogue thing?"
So, that didn't last either. I left,
okay?
>> [laughter]
>> Um
And then uh so then in 2007, my first
book came out, The Al-Qaeda Reader, and
that was like a big thing at the time
and I was actually popular, believe it
or not. Back then, I used to appear on
CNN, CB or Fox News, of course.
Um
even you may not know these, but these
are pretty NPR, which is like the most
left-wing radio in America. I had they
they used to actually have me come on.
But, before long, as I pieced it later,
I started saying the wrong things and I
started getting less and less calls from
these people. Okay? And what were the
wrong things? Well, I was saying the
right thing. I was saying the truth,
okay? And I just continued to do that,
doing my thing, mostly very low-key,
just writing articles, writing books.
And then one of my my biggest books came
out, my more famous book, Sword and
Scimitar, came out in 2018.
And um I was invited by um by the U.S.
Army War College. This is actually this
is the biggest
example. Let me give you a lesser one
right before it. Right before it in
2011, I was invited by a college in
Seattle, Everett College, to come and
give a talk. And uh so, I don't know if
you know them, you probably have your
own versions here, but Muslim activist
groups, we have what's called CAIR.
What
What a nice name, huh? CAIR. We care. It
means Council on American Islamic
Relations. And they exist precisely to
shut someone like me down. So, when they
got wind that I I had been invited at
this college in Seattle, they had they
just mobilized all these Muslims and
people protesting and they very much
tried to pressure them to cancel. But,
that this college actually didn't
cancel. And when I got there, I didn't
even know what was going on. I thought
it was going to be a small talk and I go
in and there's you know, cameras and
recorders and Muslims waving banners and
um anyway, I gave my talk and it was
completely packed, okay? There were it's
a school and there were students sitting
on the ground cuz there was nowhere. And
all of that, of course, isn't because
me, it was because they made so much
controversy, CAIR. And the talk went
through, so obviously a lot of people
want to see what this is all about,
okay? So, that's an example of how it it
backfired. But, just to show you the
optics and the lies,
it was a big thing. Afterwards, MSNBC, I
think I it's still out on the internet,
wrote a whole spread about it and it's
inclined to showing me as the bad guy,
okay? And even though this class was
like I told you, it was probably like
five times your amount. It was a big
hall and it was really full. And it was
young you know, American students who
were really interested in asking
questions. The three pictures it showed,
okay? There was one woman in a in a
burka, pure black, you know, the hefty
bag look, sitting there in the back. And
there was another Muslim man sitting
there. It showed only three people, that
woman, that Muslim man, and one kind of
I don't know, like a hippie-looking dude
who probably didn't even care what I was
saying. And that was the impression it
gave, okay? Like that's that's what it
was. Actually, it was the exact
opposite. It was a lot of people who
were happy to come and who were
learning. But, you see that's one of the
ways that the media that's how they
engage in fake news by all just by
images. But, the bigger one
um was the U.S. Army War College, very
prestigious um
military institution based in
Pennsylvania. And after my book Sword
and Scimitar came out in 2000 2018, they
really they liked it and they wanted
they invited me to come give a talk
about it.
And it was supposed to be sometime in
2019. And then like two, three days
before I'm supposed to fly out, I get a
my main contact tells me, "Hey, we're
going to have to
we're going to postpone this
for some later time, which we'll figure
out." And I'm like, "Why?" And then he
tells me CAIR and these other leftist
organizations started attacking and
writing letters to the War College
saying, "How could you bring this guy
in? He's he's a liar, he's an
Islamophobe, etc., etc." And then it
called them white white supremacists and
we feel danger we feel endangered like
this, etc., etc. And of course, the War
College buckled by by but
luckily,
enough media reported this cuz it was
kind of a scandal and a lot of people
actually got very angry about it. A lot
10 congressmen wrote a letter to Trump
about this calling it a shame for the
U.S. Army War College to actually
you know, bow to the whims of what's
CAIR is now actually in one state,
Texas, an Islamic terrorist group. Okay?
So, that's the group that's telling the
War College what they can hear. All
right? Um and also the National
Association of Scholars sent a letter,
all these professors sign up signing on
on my behalf to Trump as well. And so,
they started getting a lot of pressure,
the Army War College. And parents would
send me emails saying we're we've we've
withdrawn our children and not sending
to which and so, it became a real
scandal. So, they started contacting me
every day. But, I wouldn't answer my
phone for some reason cuz I enjoyed the
pressure and I wanted the heat to be on
just for a little longer.
And then I finally relented. And I went
and I gave the talk. And just like
before, it was a complete reversal of
what these groups wanted. Um basically,
it blew up in their face and they they
even told me, the event organizers, my
talk was the second biggest talk the
college had given after Buzz Aldrin, who
went to the moon. Again, this isn't
because of me, it's because this is what
happens when they create so much
controversy and then they don't get what
they want, which is a clo a cancellation
because people want to see what's this
all about, okay? So, that is that's
what's going on. This is the situation.
I've told you the history and the
doctrine.
The two things are incompatible.
Um you know,
and and [clears throat] we come back to
a very philosophical and and even
religious premise, which is truth the
truth must never be abandoned, truth as
you know it, okay? If the first premise
is a lie, even if it sounds like a white
lie, for example, all cultures are
equal, all religions are equal. I mean,
that seems to be a taken-for-granted
premise today, isn't it? But, it's a
lie. And if you believe that and you
built a society on that, well, the
society will be a lie and it will be
destined to failure. And by the way, a
final word about culture because and
especially multiculturalism,
I think people need to understand what
the word [clears throat] culture means.
It It doesn't mean food and dress and
exotic dress. I think that's the
problem. When you think that culture
means it's just different people who
dress differently, maybe eat differently
and have a different language. Those are
part of the different cultures, but
those are the exterior most superficial
aspects. The real meaningful aspects of
a culture is often rooted in its
religion, okay? And a lot of And I'm not
saying this This is actual I've read
books that are devoted to culture and
they all come back to saying religion is
what infuses a culture. Which by the
way, if you lose your religion, you do
start losing your culture and you sort
of become materialists,
something that I think Western Europe
should heed. But
what I'm saying is the idea of
multiculturalism, the idea that cultures
can all live together. Yeah, if it was
just about different food and dress, it
could. But the reality is the culture
and I'll give you a perfect example. If
I look at Europe, let's say Denmark.
Let's say the Danes, okay? Yeah, I mean,
culturally you probably all eat the same
thing, dress the same way roughly.
But there's the extreme right Dane and
the extreme left Dane, right? Well,
that's part of their culture. Those
views of right and wrong, that's the
culture. That's the most important part
of a culture, these distinct sets of
seeing the world and having a an entire
ethical system. That's why you can come
to a country like Denmark, uh which even
let's say it was racially homogeneous.
It's all Danes, okay? But there's going
to be a lot of conflicts because they
don't share the same vision, okay?
Just just that. And you can go to
another country that actually has
different races, but they do share the
same vision and they're actually better
off. So now bringing bringing in Islam,
okay? That is a culture that is so
antithetical to let's say Danish,
Western, Christian culture. And I don't
think again, I don't mean dress and and
food. I mean worldview. I've already
given you some examples of how they
think and they see the world and how
they want to treat it, which is okay.
You're the enemy by default. That's you
exist to be plundered, enslaved, and
hated, as you will recall that the
original doctrine I told you. So,
the biggest lie I do believe is
multiculturalism because it's
relativistic and it makes you think that
what you're really doing is you're
Imagine what's better, to have a house
of 10 people and they all have the same
values and the same beliefs and the same
moral system or to have three people who
are one way, three people the exact
opposite, three people the exact
opposite and how is that a good thing?
People haven't really thought that out.
That leads to conflict, obviously, okay?
But until you can admit it, and that's
what I'm saying, you have to talk about
the first premise. In this case, the
first premise is that no, cultures are
not all equal. Religions are not all
equal. You have to actually be honest
and objective about them all.
And um
I'll leave you now. You know, you may be
religious or not, but you know, I'll
leave you with a biblical verse
spoken by Jesus Christ, which I think is
absolutely true to our current setting
and our current situation. And it's
basically that the truth shall set you
free.
Thank you.
>> [applause]
>> Bring [music] back
the fire.
Bring back
the flame.
the fire
and the
righteousness [music]
name.